[Music]
let me lay on you when libertarianism is
to me once again I'm speaking for myself
which is about his libertarian as you
can get I do not believe I know what's
best for other people I also don't
believe that other people know what's
best for other people I can barely make
decisions for myself I do my best to
make decisions for my family should my
10 year old son take music lessons
that's a hard question for our family
you want to push him into it wait until
he really wants it
those are hard decisions I have trouble
making those for my family so making the
decision of what someone else's job and
health care should be like was in
another part of the country who I've
never met is not something I'm qualified
or desirous to do
that's libertarianism libertarianism is
taking a right unmanned your first left
on sex and looking for utopia straight
ahead to me the way I was brought up
Western Massachusetts kind of a New
England philosophy we believed in
responsibility and keeping your nose out
of other people's business we believed
in live and let live I think to a fault
my mom and dad were older parents too uh
my mom was 45 and I was born I was
raised by another generation she my mom
was my mom would be whatever 120 now 115
now whole of the generation my mom was
born are you going to see that my math
is wrong my mom was born in 1909 she's
dead now so it's a whole different
generation and my mom's feeling about
absolutely everything was who cares her
whole feeling I'm a gay rights movement
was who cares who they
want to get together with doesn't matter
to me her whole feeling on drugs I have
never had a sip of alcohol or any
recreational drug in my life that was
true for my mother true for my father
true for my sister I don't know how many
generations it goes back but never and
yet my mom always thought that sure any
drugs should be leaving if you're if
you're living in a free country do
whatever you want take responsibility
for it when you tell people about
libertarianism you just tell them we
think you should take as little from
other people by force as possible and
you should be able to do whatever you
think is right
now that's a pretty heavy thing I'm
saying because I'm saying that if
there's an eighteen year old girl who
was the greatest math whiz that we have
in this country let's say she's the
smartest person at math we have anywhere
and let's say we give her a full
scholarship to go to whatever school she
wants to go to Stanford MIT wherever she
wants to go and she decides she wants to
work at McDonald's and get pregnant
at the age of 19 that's her decision Jim
Morrison did he have a worse life
because he did an awful lot of drugs and
died at 28 I don't know I've already
lived a lot longer than Jim Morrison but
where his choice is worse than mine I
don't know I know I would not have liked
to have lived like Jim Morrison although
I'd like to look that good in leather
pants but Kurt Cobain that I want to
live like that
no not even slightly prints I don't want
to live like that but they probably want
to live like me either
libertarianism
is the strongest sense of please do what
you want try not to hurt me
our government has a monopoly on force
of a monopoly on force the government is
the only organization that is supposed
to be able to use for us the government
is supposed to be a government of us
which means in my thinking my morality
the government should only use force for
things I'm willing to use force for the
governments are the only ones that are
allowed to use guns to hurt another
person or threaten another person
legally so the question becomes what
would I use a gun to do now I'm a coward
and I have no skills with guns with
violence I've never hit a person in
anger in my life I've been hit I never
hit back so this is hypothetical but if
I were not a coward would I use a gun to
stop someone being killed yes but I use
a gun to stop from being raped yes when
I use a gun to build the library but I
take money from someone to build a
library well I'd certainly give my money
I'd certainly work I'd certainly beg you
for money to build the library libraries
really matter to me I'm I I was born in
55 from a small town without a library I
would have known nothing I had to drive
them I had to ride my bike to the
library to learn about Lenny Bruce Franz
Kafka I got Stravinsky records in the
library meant everything to me libraries
matter but that's the libertarian
question now taking care of people would
you use a gun to take care of others
that's a hard one because taxation is
using violence
now people try to say taxation is
voluntary it's not if you don't pay your
taxes eventually somewhere down the line
someone with a gun will show up they
just will some at some point if you
don't do that what do we do with our
taxes we use a gun to defend our country
yeah I guess we got it right when we use
a gun for everything we use for taxes
so when I see the government doing
something I asked myself would I use a
gun to do that now all of that being
said that is a high level the
theoretical part of libertarianism to me
in a nuts and bolt level becomes much
much simpler it is one of the cases
where that the reality is simpler than
the than the theory when someone is
worried about libertarianism they worry
about what happens to public schools
what happens to welfare what happens to
roads those are the first three
questions they ask and those are the
hardest questions I will give you public
schools
I will give you welfare I will give you
infrastructure I will not give you the
government using a gun to take money
from poor people and giving it to rich
people the biggest issue in
libertarianism is stopping corporate
welfare what we give in welfare to the
poor we give in government money to the
roads we give them money government of
the schools is nothing compared to the
money we give to rich people the best
way to stop crony capitalism the West
way to stop graft the best way to stop
all sorts of bad stuff and government is
to make government small enough the way
you stop corruption is make it small
enough the corruption doesn't pay give
the government little enough there's not
a lot to steal from them
the government is boying up the rich
corporations the rich corporations love
the government they gain the system in a
way an individual never can any big
corporation has a team of the best
lawyers that figure out how they can not
pay taxes no middle-class person has
that they have all they have regulations
set to keep other people out of the
business right even the manicure shops
you know they want a license and
register everything so that so that
other people can't get in it
limiting if you had a true free market
you would not have the big
mega-corporations
libertarianism is not about rich white
people getting a lot of money for
corporations and leaving everybody else
to whistle libertarianism is let's not
use the government to take money from
poor people and middle-class people and
give it to rich people because really
that's all that's ever happened that's
all that's ever happened in our present
climate we have somebody running for
president who we know for a fact lied
lied a lot less than other people we
know for a fact she lied and we know for
a fact that she is an insider and that
knows the way to play all the games we
also know that she knows it's better for
other people I mean know that she says
and claims and brags that she will do a
lot of killing of people overseas we
also know that she is essentially even
after I've called her a liar she's
essentially a good honest person she
essentially has a good heart
she also has a 65% disapproval rating or
higher that's Hillary Clinton there are
two things that I always believed about
modern politics one was that everyone
who would ever run for a major office
was smarter than me and the second thing
was there was no one worse than Hillary
Clinton both of those things have been
disproven by Donald Trump Donald Trump
all the good qualities I mentioned about
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump does not
share he's not skilled he does not have
as I far as I can tell any compassion
and he does not have very much knowledge
he does have a weird kind of
charisma that I cannot understand myself
doesn't even work on me but certainly is
demonstrative that he has charisma that
works for some people and he's willing
to give easy answers and being willing
to give easy answers which in his case
aren't answers they're just I will fix
it we got this problem I'll fix it well
no you don't get to say that you have to
demonstrate how you're doing it
but both Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump are very interested in getting a
lot of power for themselves
I believe Hillary Clinton wants that
power because she thinks she knows
what's best for other people let's refer
back to me saying I don't know what's
best for other people I also don't think
she does either but she believes that
and I believe her heart's in the right
place
I don't think Donald Trump knows there
are other people to be concerned about I
don't think he even knows that you've
got those two and neither one of them
that's you this is not fair to Hillary
Clinton Donald Trump is giving no
theoretical policy ideas for how
government should run Hillary Clinton is
not giving enough for my taste
here's the debate I want to see that
even a debate conversation public
conversation in front of as much of
America's wants to watch Bernie Sanders
gary johnson both Paragons both virtuous
both honest both smart both concerned
about other people both his experience
in government and I want to hear Bernie
Sanders say you know a lot of people in
this country have trouble taking care of
themselves we need a strong
infrastructure for business to thrive we
need to protect our country to protect
the people around us we need a big
strong government with a good solid
safety net that can take care of people
and treat them with compassion and make
better choices than some individuals
will make we need a government where
more qualified people can take care of
those that aren't and where we can keep
corporations at bay and we can keep some
money out of politics that's what we
need and here are some examples how we
can get there from where we are here are
the the checks and balances want to put
in place on corporations
here's want to do with campaign finance
here's what we want to do with schools
here some of my ideas but I want Gary
Johnson to say you know all those things
are problems but I think that maybe a
little more freedom as opposed to a
little more control from the government
might give us a lot of that I want
individuals to have a little more money
in their pockets and use that for
charity and use that for building and I
think instead of putting up tariffs to
keep foreigners foreign businesses out
we can actually make America more
competitive less of less taxes and let
them have more power that way and be
more successful to be more money all
over the place we can take care of
people I think that will work pretty
well and while we're at it we'll stop
the corporations by not having a big
government that flows money to them and
then Bernie Sanders says back you know
that sounds really good Gary really does
but there are some people who just plain
are going to be left out they're not
going to make it they're just not going
to make it in your doggy-dog free market
economy you just want a little willing
to throw them away and then gary says
you know maybe a maybe a subsistence
amount of money for everybody if you
just get paid just give them that money
because you know compared to what we're
playing from food stamps and all of that
stuff just writing them a check is much
easier so maybe we can do that and
Bernie says you know what you're saying
about keeping businesses over here kind
of makes sense Gary maybe we can do a
few left less tariffs and a little lower
taxes to help our corporations and maybe
that'll help a little but they go back
and forth and they cope with an impasse
where they don't agree and then the
American people say you know let's try
at Bernie's way for a while let's give
it four years of Bernie because it seems
like he he's got some ideas let's go
four years of Bernie you know Gary
you're a good guy you thought
about this really hard and he made a
really good case and we know you're a
good guy we like him we trust you but
we're going with Bernie now and we tried
that for a while and his Bernie's doing
this there's other people in the
government that go what about this and
he pulls back on this and he adjusts and
he does that and then he comes you know
four years go by and the country goes
let's hear that debate again maybe
someone else in place but whatever they
are the debate again and they go you
know we tried we don't really feel your
Bern now feel my Johnson we'll have
we'll have Gary Johnson take over for
four years see how that goes and you go
back and forth and you have a discussion
of what we want to do as a country
between two good honest hard thinking
human beings and please let's get one of
them to be a woman by the next time we
do this please and let's get someone to
be of color please let's just do that
we've got plenty of people on both sides
that aren't just white guys but for
right now my example of Bernie and and
Gary and we go back and forth like that
why are we doing that why do we to have
two people that all they agree on is
that they should have power too
psychotic power-hungry hated unpleasant
people clawing and scratching to take
power over the people's lives why not to
people who are actually having
discussion about what direction our
country should go in and by the way
we're never going to go all the way
Bernie we're never going to go all the
way Gary but that's the discussion we
have and let that go so that is what I
think about modern politics and that's
what I think about libertarianism yeah
maybe someday in the future we should go
to anarcho-capitalism maybe someday in
the future we should go to full-out
socialism but for right now can we just
do what every motherfucking American
believes which is stop giving so much
money to the corporations let the people
have more control let them smoke dope
let them put what they want into their
bodies let them have sex with whoever
they want as long as
there's consent let them do that in
every state let them love who they want
and enjoy life the way they want life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness is
that enough position
[Music]